[Music]
yes
yes yes welcome back to me uh where have
i been i've been a holiday
thank you for asking yeah
what have you guys been up to huh hi
what have you been doing huh
so i was just checking if i'm still
annoying yeah we're good to go
leave your memes on the red at 19 year
olds
in the next episode this [ __ ] tweet
has never happened i cannot for the love
of god remind
remember this tweet but i have not seen
any tweet more times in this tweet
i think about this every day i think
about this all night long i stay awake
not sleeping because i'm thinking about
this
[ __ ] mark is in marcus and
hey if we hit 140 million subscribers
double sex tape i'm in
because i'm not a coward oh yeah yeah
i knew i knew i even told martian i'm
like all right that's a great photo
but just so you know they're gonna mean
the [ __ ] out of this
and lo and behold they
god
damn it yeah i knew it looked weird
because we're i'm wearing all black
i have a torso okay it's not made up i
swear i swear also rest in peace beard i
had to shave it
i didn't look at what setting i had on
the trimmer and i just
i'm like oh great fantastic
it's fine i don't even care doesn't
bother me at all i'm just been growing
the beard and trying to grow it out as
long as possible
for over a year it's fine who cares
i don't it's just hair now i have this
[ __ ] thing
what are they gonna say that looks like
a pig it kind of looks like a pig
doesn't it huh what are they
hey kids kids i'm sure you're going to
tell me what that looks like god damn it
what else is it oh what the [ __ ]
thanks for ruining my photo god damn it
whoever you are
legends epic i respect it i like how me
and marx
said we went camping and this is the
photo we posted it's like no
yeah we went camping in a castle it was
tough
just for the record everything i have
ever said is a joke me and my way
to take a selfie with pewdiepie good one
yeah try me try my mother see what
happens
honestly i met a ton of people that
asked me for a selfie and i said no
every single time and it was epic
because people were like oh yeah it's
cool we could just talk
i think it's something that people just
think that they should ask
and then when you say no they're like oh
yeah i actually don't even want one
that's how it felt like with some people
some people were crushed and uh
it made me feel bad but hey what can you
do girls oh my god i can't wait for the
new bts song
boys we just won one thing and that is
yes
ksi got the flute now ksi if you're
listening
you got the wrong flute here i'll show
you which one you need
that's a pathetic beta flute sorry for
not getting the
specifics this is the one you need to
get it's a it's a german word what is it
called
here i got you all porn that's what you
need my dude
ah that's a flute that's not a flutter
oh sh oh you can beatbox that's cringe
yes yo
come on ksi what are you a [ __ ]
coward get an outboard
this could be you mate this could be us
i'll buy one too [ __ ] it let's go to the
it's beautiful i don't know why i'm
laughing it's really funny though
where's the video case either i can't
[ __ ] find it
post the goddamn link you please proud
to say that this sub
is no longer something hey
proud of you bros it's no september
remember that
try your best you can do this believe
i know you're going through a lot i know
you're shaking you got the sweats it's
been what a week
and no something i get it but there's a
light at the end of the tunnel
keep going say it with me
i will not stop i will not live
i will not leave it oh my god
say it hey felix it's the airline pilot
again i'm also a certified
flight instructor and i can teach you
how to fly real airplanes too
let's start with some flight simulators
first
all right i'm in i'm in i'm sliding into
dms
how the [ __ ] does reddit work there we
go the connection have been
made just for the record everything i
have ever said is a joke
i did not expect this to become such a
thing god damn
it everyone would be
yeah what do you think you had a big
dick you thought
you had to be giving oh
oh i review memes like this now it's
more comfortable
i don't care felix and jack making fun
of italian accent in mario costumes
in the back she wasn't home if she was
she would have killed this
do you think i can wear the tambourine
on my legs
oh [ __ ] i'm breaking the tambourine i'm
so strong holy [ __ ]
let's not do that me gets on the y ph
small pp
what a [ __ ] meme template jesus
oh i'm sorry big peepees but we're all
small let's get real here at least i can
do this
i feel nothing nothing
no one the camera angle in anime when a
character is about to go
absolutely insane what the [ __ ] is this
when is oh my god when i uh
when i adjusted the camera to annoy you
guys great so it's
100 unintentional all right which ones
do i know naruto prison school
death no it's a yugioh i don't know what
the [ __ ] this is
i gotta look down right this is work at
all i have no idea
just for the record everything i have
ever said is a joke god damn it
it was to protect myself from the joke
police not to get a budget
i would never cheat with you angry pasta
noises
all right all right just found out pits
and i have the same carpet i don't know
what to do with this information
just know you have a huge dick that's
the only explanation congratulations
uh i don't really have an intro people
have been making
interest
i'm sorry you know what from now on
i'm just gonna do the pewdiepie one i'm
bringing it back officially
how's it going bros my name is peter
pack yeah
yeah that's the intro welcome to lawyer
leave your memes on the reddit marcia
i'm bored
why don't you play with the neighbor's
kid
no he's a weirdo he's weird
that's a cute little template little
anime template
okay another pilot has reached out but
it is a woman
and it is no simp september showing care
respect and love to marzia
you talking to a girl what a sip pewds
oh i can't believe the [ __ ] simp meme
out of all memes is still kicking it and
i think it's reached a point where
people are getting truly annoyed
and i really appreciate that because
it's [ __ ] funny but it's
it doesn't even mean simp anymore it's
like i can't even talk to it yeah let's
joke
soon it's gonna get i feel like it's
gone even further than that where yeah
it is actually legitimately not even
funny anymore
but also i mean it is simp september so
we got a whole lot of month to look
forward to yeah
cyber sweating no what if you
wanted to build a tambourine tower to
the moon but god said height limit
er for building it's 256 block
hippies i'm in italy and everywhere are
growing
peepee stones out of the floor can you
please ask might say what they
mean yeah yeah i'll send it to her
yeah hey matsia check your whatsapp
rick actually actually never gonna give
you up
post it on my birthday this is a troll
i'm not gonna look at that and who the
[ __ ]
liked this video you guys think the simp
meme is annoying this is 10 times worse
whoa holy [ __ ] dude hand painted
that's sick that's a huge peepee right
there
flying 45s well done
i threw in a kiss there i don't know why
i did that sorry felix and sean
mimicking italians
oh god what is this old meme
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] is this what's that check it
what time
she says no clue sorry are you even
italian
swedish man single-handedly causes
tambourine shorted percussionist
worldwide in stock
yeah puppy smurf
i'm glad you guys are enjoying the the
bit more different videos i'm having a
lot of fun doing it
just for the record everything i ever
said is a joke
[Laughter]
uh sorry i'm not sipping anymore
congratulations snipe chad ow
come on he edits videos and doesn't
afraid of
anything how's it going bros my name is
peter pat
19 year olds forget i'll cater
just how's it going bro brows
hey hey brush
how's it going we're watching you're not
we're changing the way it's fridays with
pewdiepie now yeah
pewdiepie what happened to this channel
we used to be normal pewdiepie but
yeah you're right that's a good point
that's a fair point
we've never been normal
[Laughter]
just for the regular everything i ever
said is a joke every everyone with big
pee pee everyone was [ __ ]
congratulations a toast to thee
my fellow small peepee not that i
implying that i am part of you i'm just
saying you're a fellow
sheesh felix you are finally awake you
sleep a lot
youtuber amnesia bros italian wife
emilia tc's hundred million flow again
coca-cola what are you talking about
get ready for school what a journey huh
i swear to think about
just for the record everything i have
ever said is a joke all right what do we
got now
yeah i told you guys i'm not a simp i'm
gonna say i do to woman
cringe
it's no [ __ ] september and i ain't
playing the [ __ ] around
i'm not even gonna look at the woman
i think all right let's read it uh you
make your own pewds merch
because he doesn't deliver to ukraine
your posts get 24 000 uploads
you get a ton of harassment uh and
threats to the point where
mods had to close a comment section you
don't even get to
know why uh
site you editor out hey you're that
desperate to not be a sympathize you
edit out women i respect that
i respect that yeah i don't know but i
don't know what happened here
but uh cool merch very cool march
hey mod accidentally drops
pick inside the guitar the pick me
looking for the pick
i don't i don't like this one don't
don't make my unintentional faces into
memes all right i don't like it
no that was not supposed to be a thing
another one
no way i love these
it's so smooth dude i've been using them
for my live streams look they're so
dope i love them holy [ __ ] we got a new
one
all right thank you i i cannot have
enough
makes me look professional all right my
name
is pewdiepie and welcome to
[Laughter]
you look like trash you smell like [ __ ]
it's not like someone vomited
you disgust me it's time to give me what
i want
the diamond play button oh what the [ __ ]
dude
he's the one that took it have you heard
of exercise
it's good for you ah so you want to play
you want to play with me huh
whatever your mom says about you it's
all true
listen to your mother your mom has a fat
ass
[Music]
yo if he pulls out an item i'll pour you
face the consequences
that'd be sick of death
[Laughter]
you're not strong enough i fought ten
times
your size
[Music]
hell yeah
nice thank you well done hey felix your
plate one was set up the wrong way
just want to know that it could cause
damage
no and it actually did it it did break
so you weren't wrong you're technically
thank you if only i had seen this before
can you believe you get a you get a
hundred million right
you think you get something uh ah it's
so
heavy dude it's so unnecessarily heavy
but for me it's not heavy at all because
strong
[Applause]
what i did what i what i do what it do
all right let me put it back in this
proper place
[ __ ] sake what it did what it nope
what it nope
what it it there it is god [ __ ] damn
it
it's so annoying i hate it manga
anime netflix adaptation well done
netflix
they haven't ruined anything recently
have they though i feel like this meme
doesn't really
been outdated oh
okay yeah
[Music]
oh my gosh yeah of course yeah avp yeah
[ __ ]
you sit there
let's put it up kids you place your
potato wrong that could damn
[ __ ] oh my god thank you guys so much
for
flagging me this i i all right i gotta
go fix
it sorry studies show that girls often
pretend to be soft and weak around their
crush
girls around me
yes no one tick-tock thoughts room
no i gotta change the color
my stuff my phone no
that's the wrong one that's right gamers
i'm a tick-tock bot now
you all were played you all failed snow
sim september
because you simped by watching a
tick-tock thought
yeah now do as i command and smash like
on this video
subscribe and i'll see you bros tomorrow
oh and by the way you might as well pick
up the simp merch
at least own what you are sure all right
that's it for this week's the wyatt
super fun as always thank you for all
the memes i really appreciate it
i'm gonna see you guys tomorrow ah
children of nine parks
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming too
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pvp
pre-order promotion i mean
[Music]
we